[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle est sa belle nicholson de mansac
ibanez des médias noche nouvelle
émission qui zappe tout seul avec
pauwels polak match retour sollers
carrément porno longuet commence eric
brigitte cerruti vous me reconnaissez
jvc disco nourricier le goncourt à j
moins 3 + librairie you never saw that
be found comment va jean cayrol parce
que tu sais tu en as une chose en commun
c'est qu'il a publiés ton premier texte
le défi d'en écrire et en 57 dans 57
il a publié mon premier bouquin c'est
parce qu'il a fait un oui ils étaient
ils étaient ils avaient du nez ouais
comment va-t-il le père curé pas comme
juge sur la terre initial il ya 30 ans
jour pour jour
mauriac dans son bloc-notes académicien
français délicieux aussi disait qu'un
écrivain et tenait bon et puis trente
ans après je t'ai rencontré comme ça un
soir à l'apocalypse y avait neuf qui
lisait un extrait du coeur absolu et
sous son costume 18e suivait ton talent
tergal grille oui c'est pas ça craignait
un peu le jour même où il apporte quoi
n'importe quoi certains regrettent même
pas ça non alors maintenant si j'ai même
vu des bouquins de critères que tu fait
carrément des romans photos tu commences
des bouquins de photos ici pour montrer
quelque chose de très important avant et
on va si tu veux on peut regarder si tu
veux voir ça ensemble à commencer par là
j'allais pas voilà voilà voilà voilà ça
sert c'est la nouvelle science tu vois
que l'on sait que les académiciens
ancien ancien ne pouvait pas prévoir
mais voilà par exemple 2 qui
photographie dans les conditions plus
scientifique qui soit entre les années
1890 et les années 1900 douvres tu
remarques ici le miroir betty goodwin
que se lance cette jeune femme charmante
est vraiment là nous sommes avant la
guerre de 14 dans la période où marcel
proust est en train d'écrire son
chef-d'oeuvre la recherche du temps
perdu le temps retrouvé ya pas tellement
de textes de sollers pas pour le moment
à temps mais nous allons y arriver nous
commençons par la fin
ouais t'as des parts part parce qu'ils
ferment le livre
depuis absolument magnifique à ces
magnifiques selon tan hommage à tous les
morts de 1914-18 l étude de la le suaire
de douaumont c'est là dessus que les
poilus se branler oui je prends je pense
que leurs os est conservé dans ce
fantasme on fondamentale voilà alors là
c'est quand même ici nous avons la rue
la grande fresque saphique que des
femmes l'un n'ya que des femmes et là il
faut un jour revenir à proust pas
pourquoi proulx savait-il de sentiment
que les femmes étaient en train de se
chercher les unes des autres
constamment à tout instant vraiment
c'est quelque chose c'est très actuel et
en ce moment il ya fait mais arriva et
viol d'une dialyse mois là oui il faut
que le lesbianisme mais ça revient entre
oui oui il faut il faut absolument voir
une couverture de spiegel le diola voilà
nous y sommes à cause du sida
la valeur voilà ici les la pièce montée
ici alors un tout pour une sorte de
composition tu vois les jambes
le cadrage de trion parent et la pendule
en relâche jamais pensé qu'elle est
bonne il est jeune et plus je le
démontre si je m'en doutais un petit peu
mais je suis fier d'apporter la
démonstration que nos grands-parents et
arrière-grands-parents était déjà tout à
fait voter des crédits des collections
souvent très beaux jours voilà mais
alors là bon une fille là encore de
l'acrobatie ça plus populeux land art et
de la fellation celui-ci en attendant
voilà a alors ici important à mon avis
cette fille issue est très moderne il
s'agirait du jour 20 grammes et
d'ousmane des talents il faut
recommander à tous les jeunes femmes
d'aujourd'hui doivent bien regarder
attentivement et l'on peut garder le
bouquin oui tu vas plus le garder tout
le monde avoue seulement ça m'a forcé à
l'institut
d'abord parce que ce corps et d'une
souplesse
garance merveilleuse elle ressemble
trait pour trait au premier modèle de
picasso par deuxième modèle et picasso
pendant la période cubiste calais va
loin dans là on peut penser qu'elle est
en train de manger avec une sorte de
dévotion le sexe même des picasso c'est
la même époque
c'est ce que c'est ce que j'appelle le
repos du peintre des touches oui c'est
magnifique c'est magnifique a dit dans
wind ont alors le texte est où là parce
qu'on est à la page 72 ans assise à vous
ça fait combien at il a fait 44 passes
tu vois compose en fait le texte est
présenté dans le contexte de l'époque
qu'est ce que je dis je vous dis qu'au
fond tout ça ce sont des foules très
gênante pont noir et blanc parce qu'elle
représente un peu les albums de famille
qui traînerait ces gens sont nos grands
parents ou nos âmes et diamants par coup
est ce que nous avons de grands parents
faisait l'amour c'est pas évident pour
pour l'imagination des gens pour eux
c'est le sexe et eux ça n'a jamais été
la favorite c'est vrai on pense pas que
sa maman à cet âge est né oui d'autre
part dont j'ai voulu montrer les images
qui correspondent exactement à la
rédaction de la recherche du temps perdu
de proust et posera beaucoup d'histoires
de bordels de ce qui se passe en
coulisses notamment des histoires des
femmes entre elles est beaucoup mieux
proust à moi je peux le dire tout de
suite si on met ces photographies dans
le texte de poule ouais ça fait
incertaine et tu sais que les bains
douches appartenait à prout voilà qu'il
avait racheté les bas fallait bains
douches à l'époque et il venait voir les
jeunes gitton ici la bande à prémilhat
ya un motif de toi qui sort mais cette
fois c'est plus aux éditions 1906 chez
gallimard
oui et tu vas voir la cohérence du
premier une cohérence ça s'appelle
philippe sollers et surprise de
fragonard ou et alors là alors je vais
monter à 18 heures il a tu as fait quoi
là tu as fait un nom mais là tu as fait
plus de textes quand même un we can a
fait un peu partout mais c'est par une
très très belle chose et des cd détail
un bad guy jourdas tu veux que ce mot
montre-bracelet de tableau justement
tout ça se passe parce que à mon avis
tout ça c'est la même tradition qui
s'est pas foutu perpétue d'une pas mais
il faut pas il faut pas train de
l'appeler française tu vois voilà le
tableau est ce que tu as aimé
voilà un tableau qui s'appelle la
résistance inutile ou hong hao
normalement tu vois tu vois la cohérence
avec les photographes parce que on avant
par l'érotisme non en dix ans 20 ans il
faut il faut des cirés que par les
américains est arrivé voilà le feu aux
poudres
voilà et la tuer et la russie robert et
je crois que le liban rien que pour ça
le lien numérique pour le voilà ici on
est sur le détail ou de la résidence
utile si le l'oreiller et si le travail
ici les gens ça et tu vois la sensualité
x tra or di moi mon service est ce que
tu penses pas finalement que comolli
weinstein était monsieur drogue et jean
louis borie monsieur p dès aujourd'hui
tu as trouvé un filon t monsieur femmes
c'est à dire que tu as pris à un
positionnement marketing un créneau
c'est les femmes quoi j'ai il paraît
qu'il ya même une femme de dentiste
il a écrit une lettre elle allie une
tempête de neige à l'alpe d'huez cdu
femme et je me suis bien branlé
officiers qui te dis ça je le sais c'est
vrai un vote est devenu monsieur femme
quoi que oui pourquoi on jette pas ça
non non pas du tout je touche bâton
votre montre hélas pas dit une carte
postale que j'ai reçus staff du dîner
oui je reçois les tur soir tout le temps
tiens regarde ce que je dis c'est pas
joli soi même c'est joli comme tout
conçue sans péché c'est très joli livre
peut lire chers amis notre projet tient
toujours mais les dates restent encore
imprécises j'espère être à paris en
décembre new york toujours semblable à
lui même une comment et paris grande
amitié
dominique eh bien d'abord oui mais les
femmes dureront plus que le suit tout ce
que tu dis est suivie la drogue était
clos et les ans pareil d'olivennes
chahine bord il venir ils sont plus là
pour en parler mais voilà d'une part et
d'autre part les femmes c'est plus
difficile
alors moi j'ai une copine qui a couché
avec toi voyez et qui m'a dit solaire
sera atteint at on précisé
je filmais 10 solaire vas-y tu ton
commentaire après on verra si ce qui
m'aide il se nourrit sûr que c'est vrai
tu as dix arimany solaire elle mène en
solaire s'est pas aussi bien que toi et
leurs bas
je suis prêtre ouvrier elle m'a dit
solaire c'est quand même pas aussi bien
que dans les bouquins précipice et quand
même hein tu veux en elle enfin je veux
dire je veux pas précisé qui sait
c'était pour te fais un support oui je
pense que tu es aussi bien que dans tes
bouquins mieux alors à l'époque du sida
comment tu fais pas tu utilise des
préservatifs ce sont nos massifs pour
ainsi que là est très peu et très
répandues par des femmes du cerf donc tu
prends pas de précaution patrouille je
fais un petit peu attention aux femmes
que je fréquente vrai dire j'ai vite eu
les femmes qui auraient loué tendance à
être un peu de bisexuelle avant
d'interdire qui aurait tendance à aimer
les dix sexuel voilà c'est ça mais sinon
tu prends pas tellement mélangez-la en
gros ça ne demande pas beaucoup
d'efforts parce que une femme qui est
vrai plutôt les transmetteurs du sida
c'est pas vraiment c'est pas la barre
majeur c'est pas ton sinon donc plutôt
les lesbiennes vont très vite comme ça
je suis comme tous les artistes que tu
me fais rire pour comme elle à
baudelaire picasso donc à l'époque du
sida tu penses que le libertinage n'a
rien à craindre a bon tu penses que
c'est clair c'est à fond il ya beaucoup
d une population qui usurpait parce que
la taille humaine qui est interdit ouais
ah non puis y at il à bien ça pour moi
mézidon alors est ce que ce sera ma
dernière question j'attends presse quand
est ce qu'on vit il sent tu as moins de
je dirai ce que tu tues 101
ses pattes oui je vois ce que je veux
non seulement s'est passé pas une
question de performance un bouillon de
l'utilisation fonctionnalités
l'esthétique n'ont de toute façon la
performance sexuelle n'est pas important
ce qui compte c'est la certitude arrivé
exactement au point on veut exactement
quand tu es tu y arrives mis mon
prochain roman subir à la tienne
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
gérard longuet bonsoir merci d'être
robin avec nous tu viens souvent eh bien
j'ai failli venir une fois way avec
anémone bien alors tout c'est ce qu'on
vient de voir si j'ai décidé d'être
sérieux et j'avais un dîner officiel
jalousie laetitia très bien on vient de
voir mes lampes fluo qui chante des airs
de faerie melo qui était le plus grand
castrats du xviiie dès lors il était à
la cour du roi d'espagne petit fils de
louis xiv philippe 5 qui s'ennuyait qui
avait le mal du pays et donc farine et
l'ol et lui chanter ce genre de chanson
et je pense à que ça lui remonte
vraiment le moral alors je pense alors à
côté de toi michael del mar qui va
t'interviewer tout à l'heure à partir de
problèmes astral eric bergère qui a
dessiné quelques uns des femmes un des
costumes de postiers on verra tout à
l'heure florence belkacem librairie
bonsoir les roberts est l'os est la plus
belle fille de rio de janeiro et qu'on
voit en ce moment dans un film qui
s'appelle si tu vas à rio tumeur l'iao
coup dur oui c'est quoi ton job j'ai
commencé dans le design et maintenant je
pense qu'on peut dire chauffeur format
géant voulait savoir si les ampoules
s'allumer mais ouais mais j'ai pas les
principes et les prisons alors gérard en
1979 j'ai découvert que j'étais
administrateur de tf1 c'est vrai c'est
vrai j'avais fait une proposition
absolument hellzapoppin est-ce qu tu
voulais moi je trouve ça un sens et tu
voulais que on note les émissions sur qu
on note les variétés toi demain sûrement
passé ce qui avait marqué dans le
journal as ça c'est une erreur parce que
j'ai toujours été mauvais en classe
wen jamais accepté d'être jugé et je
n'ai pas envie de chasser les souris
tout fin j'ai lu que tu voulais qu'on
est des variétés le sport les bras
c'est pas vrai non par contre je voulais
quand même être le grand journal à 19
heures pour faire plaisir à la france
profonde
on peut éviter effectivement changer
certaines the way le tout les le journal
régional à 18h30 et le grand journal à
19 heures je suis à ma maman ça c'est a
dit ça est ce que tu es toujours
partisan de ça les gens choisissent avec
six chaînes ils choisissent en justement
justement à l'époque tut tut insurgés un
petit peu contre la dictature des
sondages en disant que finalement il
avait aucune raison qu'on s'en tiennent
qu'à l'audience aux sondages et que ça a
amené à faire des émissions moyennes
alors est ce que finalement avec ton
copain léotard et un autre copain m'a
delà est ce que en privatisant la télé
enfin tf1 et en permettant le
l'apparition de nouvelles chaînes
commerciales vous avez pas conduit
directement dans cette dans cette
dictature des sondages dans un premier
temps je crois oui je crois que dans un
premier temps toutes les chaînes veulent
faire la même chose
et elles sont en compétition et elle se
bat pour avoir le même public et qu'elle
danse apercevoir il vaut mieux avoir un
public qui aime une émission avoir moins
de gens mais qui s'intéresse à cette
émission qui constitue
un public fidèle et aller vers une
clientèle spécialisée au fond c'est
comme dans un kiosque de journaux dans
un kiosque de journaux il ya des
centaines de titres chacun y trouve son
compte et c'est la diversité qui fait la
solidité d'une entreprise si on veut
faire du guy lux pour tout le monde
c'est pas ça sera oui parce qu'on met
dans des émissions plus ciblées oui la
preuve
oui la preuve voilà milité dans les
rangs de l'extrême droite fin du
mouvement occident alors que diriez vous
aujourd'hui est un jeune qui milite au
tour national ça sert à rien que j'ai
déjà essayé que ça mène nulle part
à condition d'en sortir a très bien
bonnes réponses alors revenons en au
téléphone minitel
vous avez tous les partis politiques ont
décidé de surtaxer les minitel rose de
33% et on s'est aperçu que les partis
politiques avaient eux aussi des minitel
rose
cela risque le p r 1 et michael rogers
et en syrie premièrement tous les partis
politiques ne sont pas sûrs certains
surtaxer les minitels je crois que tout
le monde peut se poser la question de
savoir il ya les excès est-ce qu'il faut
pas essayer de trouver des solutions
je crois que là tout le monde peut être
d'accord deuxièmement quand vous ouvrez
une messagerie
c'est exactement comme un patron du
bistrot qui ouvre son bistrot ou même
comme un air dans une grande ville qui
craint un square vous ne savez pas quel
sera de clientèle évidemment si vous
avez un bistrot avec marc et j'ai pas
mal
gaymard ou la porno buvette vous aurez
plutôt une clientèle plutôt qu'une autre
mais si vous avez jeu par mois au rendez
vous des amis et puis que tous les amis
qui viennent viennent se rencontrer pour
se piquer à grands coups de cocaïne ou
d'héroïne
évidemment c'est un peu gênant c'est pas
forcément vous qui l'avez choisi et vous
pouvez pas toujours sortir vos clients
et dans les messageries j'étais
attention sur le fait que quand une
messagerie est ouverte tout le monde ya
accès chaque fois vous décrochez votre
les toits de vote milite elle vous payez
vous ne pouvez pas en permanence
heureusement d'ailleurs contrôler les
messages et chaque messagerie
on a le risque un jour ou l'autre d'être
squatter risée par des gens qui font des
cultes que la morale réponse paraît que
sur les messageries des partis
politiques c'est son idée mais oui moi
aussi je l'aimé dans libé celle du rpr
il paraît qu'il ya moins de police que
sur les autres par exemple fait l'essai
sur les autres messageries canton toutes
les histoires de futé et deux mineurs à
ma façon sauvage et en chasser alors
derrière la scala je vais faire le coup
à 10 heures du matin j'avais la
messagerie
je ne sais pas moi de l'évêché de paris
par exemple et puis je dis je j'admire m
cers pardon voilà bon et puis à 6 heures
du soir j'appelle la même messagerie
jeudi voyez il ya un message scandale
qui a posé le message est ce que c'est
un journaliste de libé qui a téléphoné
par hasard on peut pas le savoir on ne
sera jamais je suis longuet vous êtes
ministre des ptt
et comme par hasard une firme de
télécommunications nord américaine va
s'installer dans la meuse département
dont vous êtes l'élu
alors est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est un peu culotté de votre part de
demander comme ça une firme de
télécommunications de venir s'installer
dans votre propre département
j'en reconnais que c'est un type de
piloter oui ça fait pas que ça fait un
peu clientélisme comme sous la troisième
république il y avait des ministres qui
demandait de faire arriver immaculés ou
les je ne connais pas de ministre des
ptt qui lie pas fait la même chose et ma
seule différence est peut-être manceau
l'honneur c'est que cette entreprise ne
doit rien aux ptt
je ne lui achète rien mon administration
des commandes de rien j'ai eu un contact
je l'exploité à fond
mais je reconnais que c'est un peu
culotté et pour un libéral ça fait un
petit peu rétro non à libéral a droit
d'avoir des amis gérard ce que tu as
changé depuis les listes oui en quoi
ça m'a fait rire mais plus de modestie
je me rend mieux compte de ce qui est
possible ce qui est pas possible et je
me dis que les choses possibles sont en
nombre limité qu'il faut les faire
absolument excellent qu'on peut pas
faire il faut les laisser tomber parce
que la vie est courte et les
possibilités d'intervention sont
restreints je me sens si le train de vie
d'un ministre les voitures avec
chauffeurs les portes qui s'ouvrent
devant vous les gens qui vous servent à
table si je te disais non ça ferait
hypocrite je crois surtout qu'il ya des
commodités fantastique diffusée moi il
ya des commodités fantastique mais elles
sont la contrepartie d'un emploi du
temps où on a aucune liberté et d'une
certaine façon moi je préférerais de
temps en temps ne pas avoir de deux
chauffeurs de l'imposteur d'instituts et
d'avoir le temps de perdre du temps
marchez dans la rue rentrer dans une
boutique rentrer chez un libraire
demander le prix d'un vêtement à faire
des choses naturelles et j'ai pu le
temps de faire ça et ça ça me manque
beaucoup et d'une certaine cote de la
fin d'un côté je m'en réjouis parce que
je dis au moins le jour où je ne suis
plus midi je retrouve une liberté
fantastique que j'aie perdu depuis 18
mois mais la liberté d'aller aux bains
douches tranquillement des bières la
haye avec la cellule at elle dit c'est
magique
et quand les auteurs sera président tu
veux tu veux être quoi alors là c'est
tout à fait dit s il était président
j'aurais très envie d'avoir un rôle très
utile c'est-à-dire d'aider à ce que je
sois bien et que ça marche bien et quel
que soit le rôle d'ailleurs mais meola
vraiment envie de m'impliquer tout va
bien qu'inférieurs way pour préférer
l'intérieur n'importe où n'importe qui
peut être utile partout en gérant une
des choses dont tu t'es occupé entre
autres depuis que tu es ministre des ptt
c'est le look des postiers alors pour
voir d'où ça vient le look busty on va
regarder un extrait deux jours de fête
que tout le monde vienne voir ce soir
sur canal plus et on va voir comment
étaient les postiers il ya quoi il ya 20
ou 25 ans et le plus vieux un peu plus
vrai peut-être des années 50 jours de
fête
[Musique]
m
non
hé hé
[Musique]
allez posture bien douche c'est bien je
parlais de choisir parce que c'est pas
toi qui la faisait annoncer une très
grande consultation à travers d'abord
nos clients la presse il ya toute une
partie de la presse régionale presse
télé en particulier qui vont diffuser
ces images et par minitel clients
pourront s'exprimer
j'ai lancé une consultation au sein du
personnel et nous allons exposer les
meilleurs projets au salon des artistes
décorateurs et là où il y aura une des
visites de professionnels
on va faire brasser un peu les idées
france comptait plus que de craintes
j'écoute mais passionnant mais bhl avait
toutes les compétitions
il stagne on s'est fini la compétition
la compétition est finie enfin oui oui
il peut parler pas il peut pas non mais
il aurait tout à fait ça pour le dr
nathan l'edf pour relever les compteurs
pour relever les compteurs il serait
parfait une forte taxe ni ta famille
eric berger hertz et toi tu avions
postiers oui je n'avais tu dis pas eu
peur du saut hermès plutôt dire que je
suis un contre en freelance pour hermès
ouais ça me permet même nom
travailler sur plusieurs projets avec
différents clients et j'étais passionné
par ce par celui là parce que j'ai
toujours aimé les uniformes j'en ai
dessiné quand j'étais chez hermès pour
des compagnies aériennes ou d'autres
raisons et j'ai toujours aimé beaucoup
l'idée de l'uniforme aussi bien
l'uniforme ecclésiastique uniforme de
tous les pays du monde je serai toujours
très attentif à uniforme à travers le
monde
je trouve que en france et unis 163 de
la mode et j'aime bien l'idée d'une
entente qui reste un uniforme en
maintenant on va voir un clip de biello
qui s'appelle rhythm divine et qu'il ya
sur les basiques et chanteur je connais
charlene assise comme un billard
[Musique]
yoyo
un truc
[Musique]
et
non
legrand
hachey
françois sorte
oui
il m'a
[Musique]
soro
oui mais
où elle échoué
[Musique]
malin
oui
[Musique]
monde
et
are you
[Musique]
damman
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
voilà
oui
oh
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
défaut
[Musique]
gérard maintenant dernier épisode de
l'interview l'astro view avec le mage en
méfie toi parce qu'il a prévu ajoute
qu'un qui serait jamais président est le
cas depuis qu'elle est ministre
alors match tu as étudié à partir de
l'heure de la date du lieu de naissance
ce thème astral géant anglais second
temps près jusqu'à 2 kg ils font tout
pour être effectivement ce que le mage a
dit qu'ils seront voilà l'un jannet
président l'autre que je combine y voit
les amours match et lâchement important
les horizons très important pour vous
non plus je pense que vous êtes prétend
qu une entame très dispersé et légère
confusion enfin qu'est ce que tu entends
par là on se dira beaucoup de très très
sensible à la solitude a trait aux
visuels par exemple le lion est très
très sensible à l'aspect technique
originale a expiré qu'il avait pu le
temps tout à leur valeur n'a plus le
temps quand on est ministre de regarder
mais quand même on a besoin de rêve a
mis d'accord la droite échapper on peut
échapper
au quotidien par le rêve mais le couple
longuet va tenir ou pas moi je pense que
le couple l'onglet affronte actuellement
et affrontera en 91 les petites crises
nous venait d'avoir un quatrième enfant
quand même là non oui donc apparemment
ça ne veut rien dire avant on peut au
contraire fournir le prétexte d'une
crise dans le couple un bord gérard sans
trahir de secret si la raison là ou non
il est toujours agréable d'entendre
parler de soi
mais en général s'est rangé à bon compte
il n'existe pas verni ici pas exact et
c'est l'occasion de se réfléchit
réfléchit toujours à une discussion avec
brigitte en rentrant tout à l'heure avec
moi même en lui disant j'ai vu le match
tu sais il paraît qu'on est en train
d'emprunter une prise
non je dis en ce moment où en 91 à c'est
comment tu peux ne pas être sûr comme ça
encore maintenant que doit on va se
passer du temps quand même oui mais
enfin ça peut être retardé à bord oui on
peut repousser quand on est très occupée
par d'autres objectifs on peut repousser
de la résolution d'une crise personnelle
feront très bien merci mages alors
maintenant on va voir ce que fait le
frère de notre ami eric bergère parce
que lui dessine des costumes de postiers
ou des collection pour hermès son frère
s'appelle sylvain bergère et passe ses
nuits dans les boîtes de nuit en train
de faire des photos pour bain de minuit
qui sont vraiment chouettes et ça
s'appelle album et nous on appelle
sylvain bergère en fait mais il est
français
album sylvain bergère au bataclan
boulevard voltaire avec soupe cie
comédie 85 costumes réalisés par
christian lacrouts ce et sylvie ce qui
n'hésite
[Musique]
mon pays
soirée psycho plage bac rue des quatre
vents c'est un lundi sur deux les années
70 son retour
[Musique]
et toujours le balajo rue de lappe on
peut rentrer avec sa carte vermeil les
bains avec morena et farid leva du loup
grands bacs challes morena le guen le
ventre de l'architecte et l'architecte
avec sa fille
et les chouchous de la semaine robert
fait comment tu trouves parer à ça te
plaît beaucoup froide c'est fini c'est
génétique
je les vois toi seul elle sera l apanage
du sacré coeur notre gamme le n97 mini
qui suit une liban douche et oui et
alors tu viens pour faire la promotion
d'un film qui s'appelle située à rien tu
m'as toujours dedans avec aldo maccione
je suis un s'est faite à succès une
comique c'est même
mes films à paris le brésil d'une
histoire énorme non au oui j'ai fait
beaucoup de films d'assises c'est
combien de films au brésil 3 3 et ça
c'est ton premier film en france et oui
et sauta plus tu vas continuer dans pour
candy dont il ya un problème c'est que
moi je te trouve très très joli et puis
il ya des gens qui me disent que tu
serais pas vraiment une fille que tu
serais peut-être un garçon c'est vrai
c'est pas c'est parce que ça fait
sourire joue le rôle de travesti mettait
une montée sur un mois mais je sais pas
la classe un peu difficile quand même
devant les caméras parce que manuel me
dis que tu es un garçon alter way
il connaît pour maintenant je connais
bien oui tu crois qu'on peut le lit sur
emmanuel s'était jeté une fille c'est
pas grave si c'est possible surtout que
les brésiliennes à paris c'est souvent
cédé chez les garçons oui tu veux pas me
jurez que tu es vie
pourquoi tu veux pas le dire quand un
garçon s'est pas ses propres filles que
je suis là les papiers de juniac était
la fille et jouit le film dans le film
du jour où d'autres risqués et oui mais
pour cette gêne de dire que tu es un
garçon travesti enfilé le problème c'est
qu'on ne sait pas contre des sites pour
moi c'est d'oublier pas de ma tête c'est
une vraie femme combien de temps que tu
donnes une nouvelle femme ses enfants
ses méchants coups quand tu étais petit
déjà 2 à quel âge peut changer de sexe
et 14 à 14 heures et quel âge tu as
maintenant battre à 23 donc j'étais 9
ans qui est devenue une fille 1 il ya de
neuf ans que tu es devenu une vraie
fille et maintenant tu as oublié
l'époque où tu es un garçon je voulais
oublier tous les garçons qui font
l'amour avec toi ils se rendent compte
que tu es un garçon un ancien garçon ou
quoi comment elle vit qui se saigne
balle fille qui convenait pas problème
c'est quand on sera comme ça il ya aucun
problème
aouita problème c'est meilleur pour
rester des francs il ya des gens qui
aiment bien les deux sexes à la fois ah
oui c'est leur plaît aux garçons ça tu
sais qu'en france on n'a pas l'habitude
de ça on choisit de ces courants par les
transexuels normal mais on se fait rare
à son nom
un différend dollar contre elle elle a
beaucoup beltre métier à la france et
s'ils n'ont pas vraiment non non c'est
souvent des brésiliennes en france qui
sont des belles de jordanie liban c'est
parce que moi je suis tout de suite
merci je crois peut-être que pour la
première fois de ma vie je vais craquer
tu vois c'est possible toi qu'on veut
les institutions car opération
maintenant à la traîne
je fis l'opération s'est passée
l'opération
puis tu as toujours insectes versés à
quelque chose j'ai jamais essayé un j'ai
jamais essayé le sait bien on va essayer
en bisous
louis pauwels bonsoir michel polac
bonsoir alors le 10 octobre lorsque j'ai
ouvert le figaro magazine
et je vous ai vus tous les deux
dialoguer droite dialogue ça s'appelait
goethe absolue considéré je suis
peut-être naïf c'est pas pour moi c'est
vraiment un des plus grands scoops de la
rentrée alors je n'ai eu de cesse depuis
que de vous réunir tous les deux ici est
la première question veut opposer c'est
finalement quelles ont été les réactions
dans votre entourage est ce qu'on
voulait a beaucoup reproché via les
raisons d'abord je les vis on se
connaissait depuis très très longtemps
moi je ne fréquentais pas l'émission de
michel par volonté la jungle est souvent
vue puis quand il est quand il a eu 700
millions supprimés
j'ai pensé qu'il était temps de revoir
jeu tout simple femmes à mon désir que
le dialogue était d'une extrême
simplicité j'ai reçu beaucoup de lettres
quand j'ai reçu le ballon pour répondre
à ta question j'ai reçu beaucoup de
lettres dont une majorité de lettres
nationale c'est invraisemblable comment
pouvez vous recevra l'homme comme ça te
reprocher vous le tutoyer
le lutteur de la publicité publié des
photos de lui
enfin c'est inadmissible je ne vous
lirai plus abonnés de père en fils
depuis la genèse au figaro je n'irai
plus dur et magazines je dois dire que
j'ai reçus par contre j'ai été
agréablement surpris un certain nombre
de lettres autant de félicitations
mais moi je te félicite en tout les cas
alors dans l'événement du jeudi chaque
fois dans le petit chapeau qui est
sûrement fait par la rédaction
on dit toujours un peu là qu'il faut
encore l'appui de pauwels alors toi tu
as lu s'engueuler aussi je n'ai pas reçu
un seul comprimé et mais je regrette
rien c'est à dire que pour moi il ya une
nécessité impérieuse à notre époque
c'est de dialoguer et d'espérer que
chacun pourra changer il faut le penser
de soi-même meilleur mais il faut
l'espérer de l'autre et que pourquoi
serions nous tous figés pour le reste de
nos jours dans lé rôle que nous jouons
le seul regret que j'ai est c'est vrai
que les amis qui me l'ont reproché ont
peut-être raison c'est que nous avons
décidé de faire ce dialogue sur le thème
est ce que nous ressemblons à l'image
que nous dévoile à nous mêmes justement
voilà alors j'ai laissé de côté la
politique c'est venir en venant à
l'image vous plaignez tous les deux dans
cette interview si allemand d'avoir une
image qui n'est pas en adéquation
parfaite avec ce que vous êtes et quand
on vous connaît un petit peu je pense
que c'est vrai en commençant par tous à
louis telle image comme ça un peu facho
le sida mental alors que caen huyghe
fait la seule idéologie personne lui en
veut finalement le sida mental c'est une
façon un peu hard de dire sauf s'il est
au logis finkielkraut dans la défaite de
la pensée ou vernet henry lévy dans les
loges des intellectuels moi je pense
qu'ils disent pas des choses très loin
de poids alors ton image comme ça un peu
dur un peu
c'est injuste qu'on écrit en trois pages
et son écran 300 pages n'a pas du tout
le même attaque
et puis ce qu'on écrit pour 3 millions
de lecteurs vous ce qu'on écrit pour
10000 à 20000 à travers un livre dans un
autre mariage
je ne pense pas de la même façon je dors
du sida mental je suis une des choses
dans ma carrière mais que j'ai un peu
regretter d'ailleurs passionnant et tout
ça qu on s'excite sur des formules
tavares à petit de logistique j'aurais
dit oui mais personne n'aurait compris
non je ne regrette pas mais c'est vrai
que nous avons toujours une image qui
nous est faite d'ailleurs par les
confrères les autres médias qui ne
ressemble pas d'autres réalités
je pense euros michelin c'est la même
chose alain michel toi t'as l'image
essayer une très belle phrase dans votre
entretien à tous les deux c'est que tu
dis j'ai une image un peu fouillis merde
un peu fouillis dossier est en fait et
quand on sait ce que tu as fait avant ce
à quoi tu t'es intéressés tu dis je suis
plus intéressé par la mort que par le
prix des cercueils et finalement en
haleine je vais à l'air d'être un peu
soulagés du fait que cette émission sur
tf1 soit arrêtée parce que d'un seul
coup tu vas revenir à des choses qui
m'intéressent plus je me trompe
non il faut pas dire qui m'intéresse
plus il y a je crois et sera que c'est
important à ne pas faire des choix en
disant bon il ya la vie intérieure le
rsa compte pas
non pour moi il ya les deux la vie
intérieure la vie extérieure les deux
sont liés et donc il ya des faits de
société que je ne veux pas gommé terre
ce cet entretien qui a été pris par mes
amis comme au fond maintenant j'en ai
marre la politique l'engagement tout ça
je peux pas séparer l'ensemble
simplement il y avait aussi une
importance pour moi donner à la vie
intérieure et j'ai voulu dire bon ben
maintenant je vais revenir à revenir je
vais mettre en avant ce qui me préoccupe
quand je suis seul à seul mais ça ne
veut pas dire que je donne tout d'un
coup titus à louis cohen de ce que je
lui reprocher dans le passé ça ça peut
être le sujet d'une autre émission qui
viendra je n'ai peut-être pas assez dit
l'autre alors moi y'a une chose il ya
deux points à mon sens sur lequel vous
rejoignez tous les deux le premier c'est
[__] le bordel parce que finalement
louis après 30 ans
pardon oui non mais c'est vrai après 30
ans aux idéologies dominantes de la
gauche tu t'es attaqué comme çà à ça et
tu as dit il faut absolument faut
arrêter c'est pas parce qu'on est droite
que les idiots que j'en souffre depuis
depuis 1945
ouais et que cette domination
intellectuelle de la gauche
michael young a été insupportable toute
ma vie et que lorsque j'ai eu l'occasion
évidemment d'introduire tout autre chose
ou contre idéologie je les fais avec
enthousiasme pour vous libérer
et toi c'est pareil finalement parce que
tu as souffert de 25 ans de télé de
droite
et quant à une émission le samedi soir
la télé tu as aussi foutu le bordel
donc la même là dessus vous rejoignez
oui mais là il ya un point quand même au
jeu ne rejoint pas le gone suis d'accord
avec lui qui avait dans un certain
snobisme de l'idéologie de gauche a pesé
bien d'être sartrien au marxisme
bonoumin stabies que je n'ai pas eu
d'ailleurs pour ça que je voyais louis
pauwels plutôt que
cela mais je ne crois pas qu'il y avait
une domination de l'idéologie de gauche
dans la société français je crois que ça
ça concernait menon saint germain des
prés en sarre et les gens qui font les
journaux mais ça concerne les deux trois
jours nomination que pouvaient ressentir
un garçon qui se destinait à l'écriture
alors la revend dans les milieux
intellectuels et je parle pour moi voilà
dans le milieu intellectuel la
domination était complète oui mais dans
la france profonde y avait encore un
conservatisme et déjà touché par ça mais
par contre là où je pense que la
réaction le bon que louis pauwels est
fichue un bordel dans la gauche c'est
amusant mais qui n'est laisser
s'infiltrer des idées tout à fait
antidémocratique et même parfois
fascisante ça j'ai pas eu tant de liant
dans l'entretien mais je tiens quand
même à lui dire ce soir je pense que il
n' responsabilité dans la montée de le
pen en france
revivez messieurs d'hiver parce qu'il ya
eu par exemple ses attaques contre la
révolution française c'est figaro
magazine la part d'israël sont un
portrait de la révolution française
c'est évident qu'on relise antennes y
sur ce procès pour récents ou en lisant
furets sont les mêmes en lisant le roy
ladurie je pensais qu'il était tout à
fait justifié de se livrer un certain
nombre de révisions les conceptions de
la mer français on a su bien d'accord
robespierre ne m'a jamais enthousiasmé
je vais toujours me manquait trop du mot
à mes yeux mais
c'est pas seulement la révision de la
région sans cesse et les gens qui sont
dans l'ancien que nous avons eu plus ont
abandonné jeudi je tiens à préciser que
je suis démocrate et je prendrai les
armes si lourdes démocratie et louis m'a
dit moi aussi alors ça fait beaucoup
rire d'hermach franck dans le monde ils
ont trouvé que c'était un dialogue je
sais pas laboureur et pécuchet mais non
dans le figaro magazine ça me paraissait
avoir une certaine importance parce
qu'on peut penser que louis pauwels
avait abandonné la démocratie ou de son
journal ne jouait plus le jeu de la
démocratie
alors maintenant dès lors la même chose
qui vous rapproche la première chose
j'ai dit c'est [__] le bordel c'est
évident la deuxième chose si vous êtes
quand même et c'est pas nouveau
préoccupés par des choses importantes et
moi je suis le premier à penser qu'à
notre part mais bien sûr je suis le
premier à le penser
je suis sûr qu'à notre époque on
s'occupe beaucoup plus de l'écumé de la
mousse qui du fond des choses et quand
tous les deux vous rejoignez quand même
sur l'importance de la philosophie la
vie intérieure de vous avez eu par le
passé quand même idée les interrogations
communes voilà ce que vous rejoignez pas
beaucoup là dessus finalement parce que
c'est quand même
et quand il a fait son truc sur gurdgiev
ça en pensant à toi il a dit non mais
finalement c'est que tu le verras c'est
ce qu'il touche chez rychel
il vient très longtemps il était venu
m'interroger à la maison sur marc aurèle
et sur le stoïcisme s'il touche chez lui
cette indépendamment de l'âge qui la
donnent être un droit de réponse
je trouvais détestable et comme il se
trouverait procès le filet s'est dit
qu'on l'aimé pas répulsion là mais
indépendamment de sa une dame qui
souhaitait s'interroge sur des questions
profondes en effet qui sont essentielles
sur la ville avant
dieu par dieu voilà les questions qui
finalement ne touche tout ce dont
personne ne nous parle voilà dont les
médias j'aime bien ça chez vous dont les
médias ne l'a jamais sauf moi pas j'en
prends la liberté de temps en temps dans
le figaro magazine
et je pense que les hommes sont toujours
plus profond encore on les imagine plus
intéressant est que les médias les
définissent et qu'il fallait que ce soit
dit que ce soit manifeste dans un
journal qui paraît fermé qui est
passionnant avec ça et que j'ai dirigé
par quel cadeau non c'est pas si fermé
alors finalement ce qui vous ce qui vous
sépare par contre là j'en suis persuadé
c'est quand michel polac te dis moi j'ai
toujours pris des risques c'est vrai lui
c'est l'éternel virait jeudi à effet
direct partout parce qu'à chaque fois il
ouvre sa gueule ça c'est génial
bon et toi finalement il te dit est une
institution d'ailleurs tel institut
c'est un peu vrai ça quand même
oui c'est un peu vrai je crois que j'ai
eu besoin d'un certain nombre de
reconnaissance parce que j'ai eu une vie
difficile mais on en tout j'ai pris je
crois ça tombe de risques parce que j'ai
président risque de le déconsidérer
comme écrivain et comme à rennes
comprenant les positions que j'ai prise
car il n'était pas bon de prendre et
j'ai mis très longtemps à être acceptés
comme intellectuel comme écrivain
simplement parce que je n'avais pas les
positions conformiste du temps domine
alors dernière question louis pauwels
que penses tu de l'a5 michel tauriac
pourquoi la six alors oui la 5
je n'aurais je ne pense pas je ne pense
pas parce que je ne regarde plus la
télévision
je ne regarde que les films à la
télévision dont je ne peux je n'ai pas
de sentiment sur l'a5 et sur une autre
se regardent pas plus l'a5 que les
autres non et toi pourquoi la six parce
que c'était la chaîne la plus modeste et
que je ne veux pas être toujours comme
ça quelqu'un qui qui montre une image un
petit peu spectaculaire de moi même
c'est une chaîne qui représente ce que
l'image que je voudrais donner
maintenant c'est à dire de confidences
de discrétion est une chaîne où j'ai que
je regarde tout parce que je regarde peu
la télé puis j'ai arrêté je la regardais
unis pour des raisons professionnelles
j'aime mieux lire mais jure où j'ai vu
des entretiens qu henri guillemin que
j'ai trouvé mais un fait très bien pu
perdre et ça m'a donné envie d'aller sur
une chaîne qui recevait henri guillemin
qui est un historien avec qui je me sors
des affinités évidemment alors comme je
trouve quand même vachement d'accord
parce que vous êtes un peu dans la soft
idéologie là que vous êtes assez
d'accord finalement le fait que vous
rencontriez simple affective en danger
c'est la sortie des cétacés
voilà on a fait comme si tu es une
équipe de la télévision sud-africaine
qui allait voir des personnalités en
france pour leur parler du racisme en
france 6 g assez gonflé de la part d'une
équipe de télé sud africaine et quand
les mecs disait des choses un peu trop
méchante pour l'afrique du sud on leur
disait non mais attendez ça ça passera
pas en afrique du sud
il faudrait dire quelque chose de plus
gentils parce que ça ça va être censuré
là bas et on a vu qu'ils étaient prêts à
dire des choses plus gentil soit réussie
vous engueuler pas sur l'afrique du sud
soit plp ardisson réalise alors dit est
ce qu'on peut imaginer après
sinon un président noir
dans le futur en france on sait que le
problème ne se pose pas dans les termes
jusqu'aux états unis
mais eux à président noir je vous
signalais par exemple que le président
du sénat jusqu'à monsieur poher était un
antillais qui était monsieur monnerville
et qui était très coloré comment vous
vous aimez bien que les relations entre
l'afrique du sud et la france pas
seulement au niveau gouvernemental et au
niveau du peuple commence à pas évalué
que nous souhaitions que augmenter
l'appui s'être libéré que
le plus tôt sera le mieux un défi que je
veux dire bon parlons de mandela parce
que c'est c'est difficile avec d'état
d'urgence en afrique du sud à ce moment
on en allemand on n'a pas le droit de
cité de ce site est maintenant ce que je
voulais est ce que est ce que est ce que
vous pouvez donner votre opinion sur la
situation en afrique du sud eux comment
les choses comment vous vous voyez la
situation comme ça et comment vous voyez
les changements qui se sont intervenus
ce dernier attend là bas ça peut évoluer
par
multiplication des échanges des voyages
des rencontres vous fait une publicité
avec un homme noir plus d'ailleurs avec
un homme doit qu'avec un homme jaune et
vous avez des réactions j'ai fait une
publicité pour la cx citroën avec la
jeune fille est une star qui est une
femme
vaincus de toute sorte de mutant qui a
même plus de sexe quand même plus
drastiques et même plus de couleurs et
on a reçu des quantités de lettres de
protestation et vous fait une publicité
avec un arabe la france
les gens vont demander qu'on enlève il
ya certaines images qui sont à bout que
l'on peut pas utiliser si vous si dans
une affiche à vous montrer un arabe qui
embrasse une blanche sur la bouche vous
êtes la pile est sur la place publique
mais si vous montrez un blanc qui
embrasse une arabe sur la bouche
personne ne vous dit rien on a quand
même encore beaucoup de progrès à faire
si vous aviez la chance aussi visité
afrique du sud qu'est ce que vous ferez
comme campagne de publicité pour évoluer
les mentalités là bas moi je reprendrai
le plus beau score de tous les temps de
l'inventeur de la publicité jésus-christ
aimons nous les uns les autres comme
présentateur la télévision
si vous couvrir un fait divers par
exemple et que
a créé mais comme il va un arabe ou un
noir est ce que vous le dites est ce que
vous évitez de dire ça dépend vraiment
moi j'ai plusieurs exemples de deux
derniers mois où je les dis comme ça
s'imposait quand ça s'imposait pas je
n'ai pas dit je croyais pas que j'ai pas
de religion on a l'impression ici que
quand même que c'est une société aussi
aussi alors que la nôtre en terme de
racisme ou de crimes raciaux et sait
comment est-ce que ça c'est quelque
chose qui s'est produit dernièrement il
ya très franchement je suis désolé de
vous contredire sur ce point il y a
beaucoup moins violent chez nous en tout
cas beaucoup moins de violence organisée
beaucoup moins de violence d'état
beaucoup moins de violence
institutionnelle
pas de manifestation attendait ça parce
que ça va être un peu difficile à passer
sa chef là bas mais ici ce que je veux
dire c'est que il les crimes raciaux
individuel je parle pas de l'état mais
je parle des crimes raciaux individuel
qui se passe à marseille ou quelque
chose comme ça des bonus que les
tableaux statistiques
à vous la nôtre me paraît tout à fait
dans la norme
le médian est ce que c'est aussi
contrôler ici comme c'était avant
écoutez ça doit l'être moins que chez
vous si j'en juge par votre réaction
tout allait s'en sort mieux 1
il s'en sort bien et revin ouais moi je
trouve qu'il a il n'a pas mal répondu je
sais que j'étais intrigué par la
télévision coréenne et je l'aurais fait
avec ce n'était pas la tva par l annonce
était vraiment déçu du coréen il
l'aurait dit que ce que j'allais dire
pouvait dit dans un pays démocratique et
que peut-être chez eux dans une
dictature ça ne passerait pas je ne sais
pas ce qui s'est passé ici toujours le
problème dans ces cas là les gens sont
bien sortis mais c'est toujours le
problème quand je parle avec une poële
dans son journal j'emploierai des
phrases que je n'emploierai pas si par
exemple ils bien dans mon émission dans
la tienne donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
adapter son langage à ce qu'ils font là
j'ai quitté en face de vous fait ce
qu'il faut l'adapter à condition de ne
pas se trahir de pas trahir sa propre
pensée
moi je veux qu'on trouve que là ils ont
été assez fidèles à eux mêmes ils ont un
diplôme at mais la diplomatie ou pas
un vis très bien joué mais moi j'aime
pas les pièges je n'aime pas les pièges
pas que ce soit par sa concision de
l'information du tout d'autant que ce
gars en deux les images totalement fou
sans même temps l'afrique du sud
d'accueillir il ya des oppositions et
les gens de l'opposition
nous on peut s'exprimer ce zoo il
présente une pousse afrique du sud alors
avec un fond pays imposent interviewer
et l'obtient des fausses réponses
faisait évidemment mais on peut
s'exprimer
les blancs peuvent s'exprimer les noirs
et puis je pense à l'afrique du sud un
peu le problème beaucoup plus complexe
qu'on ne présente que il ya des
solutions modéré qui serait très utile à
l'afrique du sud et qui vont beaucoup se
méfier de propagande anti anti afrique
du sud telle qu'elle est présentée
médiatiquement en france
c'est ce que tu as répondu et toi non
non non là je le suivrai sur mon bal du
poème je perds est très bien là bas là
bas vous n'êtes pas d'accord je remercie
toute l'europe a du mal à ne sais pas
merci à tous les deux
le petit on laisse entrer les madrilènes
qui vont choses à rennes pour nous tous
on ne riait le faut on s'ennuie et
warrick au mexique au micro mais ça
c'est l'espagnol est bidon
en plus on peut mieux que nous alors moi
je t'adore parce que tous les mardis
chargé ce que tu me rend fou et moi je
t'aime bien parce que j'y aille un petit
lot parcage devient complètement
dévissée bien qu'on retrouve véritables
valeurs de l'amérique a dit m
oui c'est dur on avait un peu perdu
l'habitude de faire la fête simplement
de la fération alors je pense que le
mouvement espagnol dont le ressens comme
ça qui on ressent par à travers le deep
sea king avec qui on vit depuis des
années mais c'était pas évident de
fermino jusqu ici l ouvrir une petite
porte
ac christian et françoise lacroix qui
nous ont présenté philippe corti parce
qu'il va que nouvelle escale en camargue
à mascate lanka un port camargue port
camargue l'histoire mais marie connu à
la feria na waie la feria ça ressemble
beaucoup
distrito que je risque la tomate parce
qu'il ya le soleil s'est enfin le corti
culte est en marche
alors toi ta bille en quoi la jav est
aussi une influence flamenco le temps
ici tout le monde est complètement
dingue avec ces trucs
non non c'est pas trop alors vous êtes
un peu rire et je pense pas non c'est
fini
kadrige est en fait c'est tout à fait
de rock espaces riches grecs ce qu'il
reste à faire la fête et plus chanter
mais pour ça c'est pas en avant en date
on va en dame mais n'est ce pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vc la pomme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour parler du goncourt qui sera décerné
dans trois jours c'est bien ça françois
nourissier yens lundi
alors avec nous aujourd'hui jean
carrière bonsoir françois nourissier
bonsoir eric note
bonsoir alors jean carrière vous avez le
goncourt en 72 on avait vendu combien
millions 700 mille noms oui 14 langues
alors au hit parade des goncourt vous
êtes deuxièmes derrière malraux la
condition humaine et juste avant proust
les jeunes filles en fleur pourquoi
c'est embêtant de vos cours de fle vous
êtes entrain malraux et proust c'est
bien ton plein
le tibet le gala et moi les cévennes
franchin or ici vous pouvez pas la voir
vous enfourchez dommage parce que votre
livre en avant calme et droit
formidable il le mériterait vous pouvez
pas la voir ce que vous êtes secrétaire
général du prix mais j'ai remarqué que
j'ai publié les livres qui aurait le
goncourt depuis je donne les gens ne
disent pas les jeter
on va il choisit sa pour la voir un jour
on se bat on travaille au travail eric
woerth qui lui toute façon n'a aucune
chance de la voir au moins cette année
puisqu'il publie un essai chez albin
michel qui s'appelle lettre ouverte à
françois truffaut mais j'ai foi dans
l'avenir quand même je ne sais pas quoi
non moi sous les noms des agents
carrière c'est quand même curieux de
comme entreprise 15 ans après un
concours par amy ne de publier un livre
qui s'appelle le prix d'un concours chez
robert laffont pour se plaindre de cette
récompense
et puis vous avez un peu raison d'un
maudit quand il a dit que le titre est
un peu respectifs
livre couvre peut-être une période plus
longue c'est à dire pas de presque une
partie de mon enfance et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et j'avais peur en décrit
dans son livre de tomber sous le coup de
la fameuse de la petite phrase cinglante
de nietzsche utilisé que celui qui se
délient d'enseignants comme contempteurs
la fête s'est passé j'avais peur mais
j'ai essayé d'éviter ça parce qu'en
effet on peut tirer partie ses
faiblesses les exposants mais françois
henri pinault ici tout à l'heure me
disait une france très juste montré plus
timide y est vous êtes dégager comme le
nez des enfants qui sont amenés comme tu
en voilà c'est ça je me suis dégagé je
crois que j'en avais besoin parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai le goncourt a eu sur
ma vie des effets plutôt faste et des
fastes tu as dis que ça tombe bien
puisque l'année où vous l'avez france
françois nourissier n'était pas encore
jury donc vous ne pouvez pas lui en
vouloir
la boule sur le livre on peut penser
effectivement il ya des gens qui vont
l'acheter en croyant c'est le bon cours
je suis pas responsable
d'accord sally vous exagérez un peu
parce qu'en ce moment il ya ce week-end
200 écrivains qui piaffent pour avoir le
bon pour vous vous l'avez eue et vous
êtes en train d'expliquer que y'a rien
de tirs dans la vie d'un écrivain que je
dis qu'il ya une pierre brute par le roi
et qui respire de le voir dans certaines
commissions parce que je sortais de
jeter une quête j'étais personnes je
n'étais personne ne sortait un trou
comme le vide
et si j'avais si vous voulez préparer
une carrière au plus plus lente plus
mesuré je crois que par exemple je
prends pas les permis avaient tiré à 120
concours mon éditeur me dit qu'ils
seraient 200 milles j'aurais été
beaucoup moins ennuyé avec qui arrange à
200000 exemplaires sans bon coup qu'avec
un bon courtier tirer comme ça vous êtes
riche en 1720 experts écouter alors là
je vais vous dire bon l'état et en
suisse alors attendez attendez attendez
là je voulais pas vous dire autre chose
c'est que moi j'ai suivi le choc
pétrolier
ça veut dire que j'ai donné ma large et
à la balle comme c'est pas du tout vous
servir de l'argent avec je m'en fiche
c'est quoi on peut pas habitué à ça bon
ben là
il a bâti à pouvoir acheter des lingots
comme je le dis si l'on peut acheter 200
m brasse et m la chaussure est riche et
bon mais il a acheté des actions et à 74
il ya eu 40 % de dégringolade les
parlons un peu de littérature par la
littérature
vous allez décerner ce prix lundi enfin
j'espère mais il paraît que ce sera pas
facile mais si en plus vous vous dites
que le lauréat va vous casser du sucre
sur le dos dans 10 ou 15 ans voilà
beaucoup dans 15 ans
[Musique]
non mais je juge écoute attentive aux
jantes ariel j'ai lu attentivement son
livre et j'en ai tiré la conclusion qui
s'impose c'est qu'il vaut mieux être
inconnu pauvre vieux et n'est que
célèbre riche beau et jeune
une fois qu'on sait ça donne tout une
autre morale que ça va devenir très
simple de certaines banques ou de ne
donner que de la voir non bien sûr ces
lieux de là bas moi je m'appelle en 68
j'avais dit dès le maître de maison et
le
le jour du concours il y avait devant la
maison les voitures y avait la bleue du
rtl avait l'art cogérer la jaune y avait
la bleue et dans toutes les voitures des
radios et des là sous la porte des et
attendait alors je voyais par la fenêtre
les voitures je disais bon et puis vers
1h une on a entendu prendre où tous les
moteurs se sont mis à tourner que toutes
les voitures sont des partis comme au
cinéma comme ça par contre j'en ai pas
fait j'en ai passé un tel drame
je veux dire j'ai fumé le drame de
l'avoir frappé par cinq voix contre 5
vous d'avoir lui-même mais non il faut
prendre tout ça avec un peu de distance
c'est un paradoxe que vous siégez
antérieures mais pas le même puisque
quand même je vous avais un peu tôt dans
la vie dans la vie littéraire en kick
ass est le héros de votre livre est
quelqu'un a fait un cours unique
constant du passion les chevaux et dont
on se demandera jusqu'au mot fins il a
réussi pour gagner sa vie aussi les
passer à côté donc peut être les plus
rapides sont des plus beaux romans qui
lui réussit en général
je crois qu'on fait des romans avec des
vies possibles le problème est pas
savoir si elles sont ratées ou réussis
mais qu'est ce que ça aurait donné alors
il m'est arrivé de faire un roman sur la
question si j'avais été un timbre qu'est
ce qui se serait passé ça au fond c'est
un roman sur si j'avais été écuyer
lorsqu'à 20 ans j ai pensé à vous c'est
le bar des hausses encore plus loin si
vous l'aviez publié sous un pseudonyme
vous pensez que les gens et devinez
nourricier derrière ce livre bien celui
ci non je ne pense pas donc ça prouve
que c'est un vrai roman ça prouve que
c'est un vrai roman et que peut-être
bien joli coup à jouer mais il ne l'a
jamais filon du caire mais c'était
peut-être que ça va le suivre tout à
fait d'accord c'est parce que il y avait
un style nourricier et puis sa défaite
vous fait trop de crédit aux lecteurs
professionnels
alors justement vous êtes en train de
lire plein plein de plein plein de
moments là dans trois jours nous
distinguons course et les pronostics
pronostics ce serait indécent d'en faire
trois jours avant cet objet d'en donner
un les pronostics au tiercé entend
donner cinq ou six on peut donc on peut
dire on peut dire sans amertume et son
méchant c'est que ce n'est pas une année
très faste alors c'est vrai et qui va se
passer probablement ce qui arrive
mauvaise année autant un prix comme le
prix goncourt c'est que chacun arrive
avec un livre préféré
très souvent une c'est une scène qui n'a
pas de chance de bien triompher son
point de vue alors très vite dans la
discussion il se rabat sur un second
choix
et puis peut-être ensuite dans la
discussion sur un troisième soit peu
sortent finalement les prix sont souvent
des compromis entre les 3e choix de tout
le monde et pas du tout à nous en
collectif d'affaires blesure mais qui
leur à lundi
alors dans la série les argentins sont
formidables après alfredo arias qu'on a
reçues dans la première édition et qui a
donné son nom au salon arias nous
recevrons les invités de marque
ce soir nous aurons la chance d'avoir à
roberto que la terre qui est le
décorateur d'alfredo arias depuis depuis
le début le mans où il est à paris d
sa mère c'était pas grave ouais copé au
théâtre de l'épée de bois c'est ça y est
les 25 créations qui fait les courses et
je n'ai participé à 18
c'est toi qui a fait la maison qui
s'ouvrait pour comédie policière c'est
ça ou le chariot c'est magnifique chalet
où c'était extraordinaire
je travaille aussi avec marguerite duras
est arrivé
ça va y ait deux fois savannah bay ouais
et la morosité la mousse et bien voilà
quoi il ya un truc c'est qu'en fait tout
le monde se connaît parce que c'est
effectivement le décorateur daria c'est
duras mais c'est alimentaire parce que
ton ta vraie envie c'est des peintres
oui c'est pas d'avis et une patience ils
ont envie cette impression et j'ouvre
simplement qui est la dernière fois que
j'ai exposé mes toiles à paris c'est au
centre culturel démarrer et ne valent
alors j'ai eu un bon moment de silence
où j'ai travaillé 1 et maintenant le jeu
montre 75 tableau on comprend les femmes
seules ici c'est bien ça cogite chez moi
je viens et aussi dans la galerie
d'analysé sassi hockey l'hôtellerie
alors franck loubert à réaliser un sujet
que je trouve formidable parce que c'est
du cdu plate et plein cadre
ce qui fait que si les téléspectateurs
mettent leur téléviseur près du mur ils
auront l'impression d'avoir chez eux
un tableau de toi alors on va le
regarder c'est une très bonne idée de
francky
commentaire ma gueule l'homme parle il
dit que ses toiles ne sont pas toutes de
la même grandeur on pourrait le croire
mais non elles sont deux formats
différents
cette différence chaque fois différentes
poses un mystérieux problème à cet homme
[Musique]
quelquefois on peut mélanger les grandes
toiles et les petites toiles cette fois
ci ce n'est pas possible il ne sait pas
pourquoi mais il sait qu'il doit en
tenir compte
cet homme parle beaucoup
la distance qui sépare les toiles il dit
qu'il voudrait presque rien quelques
fois et peut-être parfois rien qu'elles
soient collées l'une l'autre
oui quelquefois il ne s'est pas au fond
il est dans le même état que nous devant
cette peinture qu'il a fait déborder
on peut dire aussi ces choses là
qu'il ya aussi les bestiaux sans
identité des postes boursouflure de la
douceur d'une très ancienne peinture qui
allait les howett identifier les signes
il ya des signes là devant nous ils ont
l'air d'être des choses et aussi des
troncs d'arbres qui partent quitte
les tronçons de serpent de mer dans d
humilité de sens de mousse et russes
allemands des surgissements
bien
le rapprochement possible entre l'idée
la chose
la permanence de la chose et son inanité
la matière de l'idée de la couleur de la
lumière et lieu c'est quoi encore on
peut toujours dire que vers le haut
quand on remonte vers les forces dans le
ciel peut-être y aurait-il un visage
d'un enfant qui dort libre il a dit
quand on était avec le ministre des ptt
tout à l'heure que tu étais un
performeur alors c'est comme ça que
s'afficher la paire femmes c'est pas le
problème partout où je vais ça devienne
performance je dois dire que j'ai vu
quelqu'un billets comme ça c'est mon
ambition c'est bien mais qu'est ce que
c'est un ami qui m'a donné pour moi ton
club tu es tellement bien marché le
tabou l'année dernière les gens disaient
qui est pas mal ecstasy c'était bien
parce que ce sont les gens c'est tout ce
qu'il voulait chaque fois j'étais
d'accord
temps en temps c'était vraiment cinglé
enfin les gens comme boy george comme
jean paul gaultier on va impliquer pas
mal d'idées ça te fais pas chier d'être
des pauvres alors qu'ils sont quand même
je fric et toi moi je suis très flatté
parce que j'adore boy georges dor jean
paul vettier façon quand on est limité
c'est la meilleure façon d'être respecté
c'est pas un pee wee herman anglais je
pense jeu différent oui à beaucoup plus
de références avec le passé et je mets
mes lunettes parce que vraiment est très
brillant tendances et les beuveries une
autre verte appelée madame veuve à rim
c'est comme tu veux des pas de problème
par moi ton ami trop jeune trop jan
c'est vrai qu'il a essayé de se couper
le lobe de l'oreille
en fait il voulait ce coupé l'oreille
complètement mais il avait des mauvaise
isolation il est vachement de mal
il a juste plus couper le pain n'est pas
le dernier painchaud père je pense
effectivement que je représente l'esprit
du je suis très bien où tu détestes les
yupiks poids liée au ps ya fait payer à
p&g pas je pense que mon prochain loupé
ce sera peut-être le peuple qu'il faut
réveiller le chouchou maintenant mais
réveille-toi c'est l'art du chouchou de
la semaine c'est le chouchou de la
semaine c'est quoi le sceau de la
semaine oui les dernières inférieur je
connais bertolucci à l'oreille comme les
voilà maintenant tout le monde attend le
film et la musique du film qui va
résulter sakamoto est d'éviter à tout le
monde
ouais c'est le genre de musique que
j'aime mais quand je veux prendre mon
bain qualité david sylviane ça va
confondre avec david bowie
moi je préfère avaler
ouais mais c'est très beau et à chaque
fois il ya aussi encore ils chient satin
moto encore que d'autres s'appelle succi
yamamoto
il ya un dernier parce qu'il faut en
parler parce que c'est un retour jeu
depuis qu'il s'était passé
la caméra histoire le temps la wii fait
passer à paris c'était vivre c'est
maintenant il revient d'un groupe à
force c'est un jeune homme fait c'est le
nouvel album ouais c'est très bien
dans les dents les trois chouchous
callas et lequel le super chouchou parce
que chaque semaine tu nous fais au moins
cet avis il garde ses david sylviane
noël en face c'était ça avait été
importée par les forces parvient avec le
feu quand même la planète est en jeu ici
à autre les dunes de calais tu aimes les
gars toi tu aimes les quarts
[Musique]
m
ras le cul des rosbifs virez moi ce clip
de merde et vival flamenco
[Musique]
noche outils bonsoir alors toujours
entouré très jolie femme la mieux
habillée avec ta collection étaient 88
est ce que tu peux nous dire dans quel
esprit tu a dessiné cette collection je
suis resté un peu sur l'idée qu' il faut
quand même décliné la femme moderne
on ne peut pas la faire sauter 80
beaucoup d'extravagance je suis pas
partisan des ça je pense que la femme
moderne assez de personnalité pour aimer
de sa vie' avant tout pour soi même un
peu pour les autres et pas pour jouer
dans le feutre au personnage de
spectacle
alors finalement un lit nous c'est un
diminutif un petit peu je veux dire
petit puis à la même heure de nino qui
est à biella qui de temps en temps et
pas très gentil avec toi qui
t'engueulent quand il fait des choses
qui sont pas bien et est à la tête d'un
groupe énorme cet été dans combien de
pays aujourd'hui mais je suis dans tous
les pays on peut effectuer en tant que
livre comme elle ajoute kenny non c'est
aussi tout ce qu'on a fait beaucoup de
restaurants est allée les saluer affirmé
sana
le mienne vient de la diminution de la
toile et anthony se donner un peu une
allure est gentil mais comme une licence
et un jeune et un peu plus d'une
cinquantaine
c'est énorme et un énorme disons assez
assez grand et juste avec sa 2e plus
grand que tu regrettes pas un peu
l'époque où finalement tu étais un peu
comme sa dolce vita playboy ou tu avais
encore plus des jolies femmes autour de
toi ou tu passé beaucoup plus de temps à
une boîte de nuit n'ampute et j'en avais
moins comme nombre mais était plus
proche peut-être éventuellement mais
évidemment réserve toujours à toutes ces
choses confortable mais je crois que la
vie est faite toujours d'une succession
de paris dans lesquels on laisse
toujours un peu une place confortable
pour s'aventurer l'aventuré fascinante
on trouve de nouvelles
mention après on regrette un peu on
imagine même en confortable autour
étaient beaucoup plus doux est facile et
finalement tout cela ça fait partie du
champ de ce miel veilleuse aventure
qu'est la vie il faut le vivre quand tu
danses un parfum pour femme qui
s'appelle nino cerruti pour femme tout
simplement important pour la vie quelle
est l'implication de quelqu'un comme toi
dans un tel parfum est ce que c'est un
jour des gens qui disent voilà le parfum
qu'on a inventé pour vous que vous
mettez votre nom dessus ou est-ce que tu
interviens dans l'est dans la
fabrication et dans le dans l'image du
parfum quelle est l'implication de
knight the park j'ai suivi la procédure
habituelle citrique aspiré dans mon
travail loin tout ce qui porte mon nom
j'aime bien de le loire à fond le vivra
son ce qui me fascine de ses deux
métiers
c'est que d'en importer ce qu'on fait il
faut exprimer quand même une idée une
image une certaine idéal commun et vite
c'est évident qu'avec un parfum femme
tout cela c'était un peu le maximum de
tout cela je considère presque était
cette femme et pour mon nom maintenant
s'ils dominent chose que je fais parce
que l'on dirait tout le monde est dans
son du point de vue de l'aspect
extérieur des lignes du racolage et du
jeu de même tout ce qui me fascine
m'intéresse d'une femme qui était
toujours un peu de moteur qui m'a mené
dans sept vies et à vivre d'enseignement
de la langue kabyle
non seulement les femmes qui vont
s'absenter boutique mais tu as vu aussi
des stars que sont les stars que turbine
mais en particulier il y en a une que
depuis trois ans mais manger un peu avec
elle attend que sa façon de s'habiller
que ces quatre litres mais je dans les
italiens quand il fallait mais kathleen
terne et quelles sont les stars du passé
enfin des stars qui sont décédés
aujourd'hui de liu ne l'attendait pas
que tu as aimé habillés mais sans
oublier un certain nombre je peux dire
que pour exemple j'ai fait les derniers
pantalon sous mes yeux pourquoi prochain
n'est pas raison un peson on peut la
danse et le récital en général et
j'avais marlene dietrich à la boutique
il n'est pas venu acheter des chapeaux
j'avais fait tout les chapeaux de roue
raison mais quand il ya quand même deux
héroïnes qui sont évidement de
personnages qui me sens très proche et
catherine est pour
ça c'est ton style de femme absolument
ça c'est ça arrive on le retrouve
d'ailleurs dans nos projections rien
phénomène qui étonne tout le monde dans
le monde entier aujourd'hui c'est les
nouveaux comme deux tiers et c'est à
dire il ya berlusconi à benton benedetti
à toi commence moi je suis ravi d'avoir
même que plus petit fille d'origine
italienne suis ravi que les italiens se
je suis ravi que le flamenco soit en
train de planter de rock and roll
je suis ravi que les italiens les
affaires soient en train de tailler des
croupières aux anglo saxons la tue
finalement tu attribues sait à quoi ce
cette reconnaissance finalement de
l'italie je crois que en tout cas je
sais pas si chez les italiennes c'est
mieux qu'ailleurs mais seulement chez
les italiennes il ya comme une certaine
fantaisie et incertaine amour pour la
vente sûrs que ça les pousse un peu a
essayé à oser à tenter et apprend les
choses avec peut-être un peu plus de
décontraction est avant tout une autre
grande qualité je croyais c'est pas un
peu moins au sérieux
ça aide beaucoup étant sérieux je passe
sur mon jeu et oui je crois que oui vous
savez en italie ça fait 26 ans qu'on est
habitué à voir du recul devant la tuque
content d'être là à seulement et vient
aux bains douches de temps en temps non
franchement non pas dans quel bois je ça
tu sors encore où je n'ai plus du tout
des voyages à vous que j'ai sont plutôt
dans les boîtes
parce que c'était me lever le temps où
je courrais derrière des fils rentrer
dans une boîte pour boire un verre et
regardez c'est légèrement ils n'ont pas
toujours plus derrière les films de
parce qu'à berne
il faut quand même lui tresse des
lauriers sont les portes oui mais je
peux faire
paul henri de bodinat je t'ai connu tu
étais chez actuelle avec biseautés
essayer de réparer les finances
actuelles
c'est dur tu es arrivé à peu près
apparemment ils n'ont pas encore coulé
avant ils vont très bien
après tu étais chez dupuis cette chine
qui a dû puis qu'est devenue cette fille
pendant que tu y étais d'ailleurs était
devenu directeur général
oui et puis maintenant tu es président
de cbs en france on y verra quel âge tu
es devenu président de cbs france compte
six ans c'est bien j'étais le plus jeune
président d'une grosse société de
musique en france à l'époque peut-être
mais je crois que lévis avait été
président de plus encore est uniquement
via un scoop a commencé hier matin c'est
ça la cmm tena monsieur dean alors c'est
quoi
ben maintenant la première télé on
parlait un we have asie maintenant ce
qui se passe c'est qu'on est toujours
filiales je pars de cydia fond d'une
boîte américaine qui s'appelle sylvie et
ce disque inc mais que les actionnaires
cette boîte c'est plus monsieur lawrence
tynes ou des banques américaines c'est
faux ni seul ni les japonais ont racheté
columbia maintenant déjà le mal en bien
des années 30 et tous le colombier à la
grande époque a été racheté par les
japonais tout à fait exactement été
racheté par sony enfin la société
american way a comme seul et unique
actionnaire
sony est est ce que tu trouve ça triste
toi ah non moi je retins formidable ça
va donner des moyens de faire un truc
moi j'aime beaucoup les japonais je
trouve qu'ils ont ils raisonnent à très
long terme
or dans la création consignes les
artistes soient établies soi-même jeunes
on a intérêt année à long terme
donc je pense que le fait de faire
partie du groupe sony maintenant pour
cbs voudra dire plus de signatures plus
de risques à prendre en termes de
signatures de nouveaux artistes
donc finalement ça nous permettra sur
encore mieux notre métier que justement
signé les artistes est ce qu'ils vont
nous regarder les japonais je suis ivre
il rend pas mes pieds pour je rêve c'est
quand même pas tout dire je vais être
obligé d'apprendre les japonais n'ont
pas du tout j'ai une secte interdite la
mienne qui parle japonais un petit peu
de dire à un gars une fille de tokyo as
tu vois bien là tout va très bien
bon voilà maintenant on va voir les
wannabe tu sais ce que ça wannabe henry
non parce que je regarde par anthony
alors à wana vie c'est qu'avant disait
newcomers étais tu sais que la sienne
celle veut comme emploie des mots
français
là on appelle ça nous dévoile à vie à
cause de la chanson des beatles à wanna
be your man alors on va voir maintenant
les wallabys de la semaine c'est des
gens qui un jour peut être fâché parce
ya des gens qui chantent là dedans mais
un jour tu verra arriver chez toi chez
cbs des gens qui ont été levés lundi
dans 20 minutes que lui ferai mon
habillement blues non plus
quand je travaille sur palette graphique
j'ai un projet de film d'animation en
trois dimensions le sujet c'est une
fille qui est dans son hlm qui
s'ennuient et qui rêve d'aller se
balader dans cosmos alors tout est prêt
sur le papier le storyboard céleste
existe parce qu'elle s'appelle céleste
mais je suis à la recherche d'un
financement pour réaliser ce film ou
éventuellement d'une société qui me
permettra l accès gratuitement à son
matériel
si ça vous intéresse vous pouvez me
contacter au 48 39 18 29
bonsoir je vous présente tiriou 135 ans
architecte voisin atterri dans une
crypte d'artisans 14e et moi je vous
présente amène arrietty 30 ans artiste
peint est la première création aux côtés
d'un pilote tel que les prix jeunes
créateurs 87
nous étudions actuellement la gamme
babylone et nous vous présentons ce
niveau les modèles arbalète qui saisit
les marchés bien que sa portée vous
donnez votre avis aux 45 81 51 cents
bonjour jimmy gagné trente trois ans
pour lutter contre le roc qui
s'essouffle nous avons conçu le kin
france le guide national du rock en
france avec toutes les principales
rubriques les groupes les studios les
salles de concert et cetera je pouvais
trouver thirteen france chez vos
disquaires par correspondance aux 102
avenue des champs elysées dans le
week-end à paris et pouvez nous joindre
45 45
20 14 66 bonsoir je m'appelle valérie
zad
j'ai 23 ans je suis pas triste rappeur
bon j'ai un petit problème c'est que
j'étais venu vous voir avec plein de
tableau et leurs élèves cette émission
les a tous acheté ce qui fait que jamais
plus
ainsi tout le monde voilà si vous voulez
en voir plus je suis à la recherche de
lieux d'exposition alors contactez moi
excusez moi une dépêche d'un minutes un
jeu ni invitation
valérie zad exposé 10 en novembre au 2
décembre au centre culturel andré
malraux à orsay dans l'essonne
c'est super écoutez il faut que je vous
laisse j'ai du travail alors si vous
êtes un auteur et vous cherchez des
illustrateurs contactez-moi s'adresser
valérie z 69 28 81 commence merci madame
bovary est ce que tu aimes do you like
patrix music
j'ai toujours aimé la logique de
peintres et qu'il était chaud sur avis
qui reviennent à l'état sa partie
tellement long façon il appelle à
beaucoup plus de matches cette année
il est exactement comme sur les poses et
en plus il parle alors patrick moi je
vais te dire un truc je vais pas te
demander ce qu'on t'a demandé dans les
50 émissions de télé que tu viens de
faire
qu'est ce que tu as fait pendant dix ans
parce que finalement je m'en fous moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est que tu nous chante
ton titre en ce moment qui est vraiment
bien et puis tous les succès
effectivement comme america où sont les
femmes
faut pas rêver et ça ça nous fait
vraiment plaisir l'amour avec les yeux
sauf que je vois pas très bien à travers
les alors vas-y bon gars patrick juvet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en ai traversé pour des nuits qui
n'ont
finissez pas
le rêve
arrêt
peut-être pas
tant connu
qui n'avait jamais d'eau
même dans mon piano
il n'y avait plus de mots
j'ai joué
et j'ai eu peur des ouf
denis
froid
tu vous
vous mêmes
[Musique]
toujours tout seul à
d'abord t'aider
dans un bruit d'enfer
le ciel
tombé
[Musique]
non
qu'avait
[Musique]
m
sourire
[Musique]
les yeux
et des gens riaient rien mais je
l'entends
c'est violent
et moi j'étais
[Musique]
je me suis
on ne sait toucher
je pars
oda
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sourire
[Musique]
m
un sou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bush
m
je sais
[Musique]
non
ah ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec mon jeu
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le pas
j
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle sonne
[Musique]
john a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aussant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on ne peut rien
avant ce pas pourtant
[Musique]
ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a fait ça
m
et une femme alors
[Musique]
auto banking
tout comme
[Musique]
ah ah
oui
[Musique]
non
l e
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
thème est
or
pareil
[Musique]
faut paraît
les apparents
enfin pas tous
je tourne un peu
tél
mais monde
c'était sûr
paraît
je ne sais pas
j'aime
parti
[Musique]
en moi
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
si vous
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
la vanne
[Musique]
mais tu m'as
même sous la
pour quelqu'un
[Musique]
moi
tu comprends
[Musique]
que l'an jours
m
[Musique]
en
battant
arrêt
du côté
je suis tout
[Musique]
les oiseaux meurent de
[Applaudissements]
à
moi je
[Musique]
et la fin erreur
entre nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus